hey everyone persia here and twitch
rivals just hosted an
amazing apex legends tournament
featuring some of the best players
streamers and creators on the platform
legends such as octane and bloodhound
are dominating the meta right now
intel movement and teamwork are three of
the magic ingredients for winning games
and
for my marvel 3 heads out there octane
and bloodhound are reaching doom
virgil levels of pick rate by being a
great shell for any team
that's why we're breaking down some of
the best octane and bloodhound plays
from the tournament
and showing you why you should consider
picking up these legends if you haven't
already
ever since octane's jump pad was buffed
players who use it can jump higher and
further which has opened up a whole new
world of movement
and positioning nothing spells that out
more than the clutch plays from team
love abilities at the end of game three
on olympus
down to the last five squads and
approaching the final ring
jump pad allows abralele to quickly take
control over the highest point within
the icarus
one player is separated from the team
one player is down
and the other is alone and attempting to
res in the bubble
this gives the perfect opportunity for
aberle to rush down the duo
and flank the lone squad member this
kill is actually what wins the entire
game in my opinion
but we'll come back to that later aberle
recognizes that this position
is awkward but not terrible as there are
only three
squads left in apex the slightest bit of
cover is all you need and the position
behind this box is good proof of that
dropping a medkit was also crucial here
because lovabilities was completely out
of heels
and shields luckily the game saving kill
i mentioned earlier gives her the much
needed shield swap
that was followed by the perfectly timed
jump pad to secure
the third party ambush and the win
avrily's ability to recognize when to be
aggressive or
passive shows exactly why this team were
the champions of the event
the second half of the tournament was
played on world's edge but the entire
time i was watching from my seat's edge
because every game was intense and down
to the final round game 5
specifically had some stellar octane
plays starting with imperial howl and
fragment
and ending with pvp x in skyhook
imperial hal kicks off game 5 with some
clutch plays from floor to floor and
fragment
using the jump pad to block doorways and
prevent enemies from easily rushing in
almost immediately since two enemies
flying
secures enough damage to keep them away
for the next few moments
and gives hal more freedom to make his
way in and stop the enemy rez
the cherry on top is patiently waiting
for the recovery of the bloodhound
breaking the door
to clutch the fight we see later on in
the same game that putting those jump
pads in the doorways is an extremely
effective strategy
as team jake and bake live stands their
ground in a chaotic in-game scenario
but aside from blocking off doors the
main way to use the jump pad
is for those quick and easy rotations
which make all the difference
at a moment's notice with only four
squads remaining pvpx calls for a jump
pad rotation to the top of the train
station
as the remaining teams are all fighting
on the ground floor
the takeover of the high ground forces
team love abilities to reposition
underneath the station which was
actually crucial for the remainder of
the match
and allowed team jake bake to clean up
the remaining teams left in the open
once the final ring begins to close two
major things happen
team love abilities make a jump pad play
of their own to ambush the high ground
but one teammate doesn't quite stick the
jump and gets left behind
this allows pvpx to help take down two
enemies and fight fire with fire
or in this case jump pad with jump pad
as his recharges just in time to escape
from the ring to the only remaining
cover
a big blue box this cover gives pvp x
just enough time to pop a bat
and clutch the win but i would have
loved to see team love abilities use
their jump pad to hop to the cover
behind the blue box
and allow the ring to push team jake and
peak off of the high ground but
it was an amazing act of surprise that
might have gone down differently if the
whole squad was able to make it
regardless the entire tournament was
extremely fun to watch and made a few
things
very apparent octane and bloodhound are
the perfect recipe for
intel and positioning two of the most
important qualities to win in the game
acting fast and optimally are both tough
elements to master on their own
but when it's combined any situation can
be turned around
but of course none of that matters
without teamwork we may have focused on
octane
and bloodhound as legends but all of the
players working together is what truly
makes the combination powerful
no matter what level you're competing at
i hope you
enjoyed the breakdown of twitch rivals
and if you want to see more videos on
apex legends
then be sure to like and subscribe to
gamespot for more
[Music]
you